Trascrizione: Nicla Crescini
Revisore: Giorgia Borsellino
L’Italia è una Repubblica democratica
fondata sul lavoro.
Articolo uno della nostra Costituzione.
Nell'articolo quattro si sottolinea come
il lavoro sia un diritto e un dovere.
Ma il lavoro può essere anche un piacere.
[IL LAVORO PUÒ ESSERE UN PIACERE]
Se noi iniziassimo a considerare il lavoro
un piacere, cambierebbero tantissime cose.
Cambierebbe il modo di cercare lavoro,
di svolgere un lavoro, di creare lavoro.
D'immaginare i nostri capi,
i colleghi, i luoghi.
Provare piacere a lavorare, essere felici
lavorando è possibile sempre.
Ed è raggiungibile
da chiunque desideri farlo.
Si tratta di conoscere se stessi
e di credere in noi stessi.
Di sapere chi siamo, cosa siamo
in grado di fare, cosa ci piace fare.
Prepararci.
Cercare attivamente
un lavoro o crearne uno.
E poi fare la differenza.
[LE PERSONE FANNO LA DIFFERENZA]
Che siate imprenditori, liberi
professionisti, dipendenti, non importa.
Tutti i giorni avete a che fare
con altre persone e potete scegliere
se essere gentili o non esserlo.
L’eventuale sforzo,
se sforzo deve essere, è identico.
Ma i benefici sono ineguagliabili,
e sono tantissimi.
Ma ve ne cito solo tre.
Il primo, forse quello più ovvio,
è che praticare gentilezza
è di immenso aiuto agli altri.
Significa riconoscerli ed essere
riconosciuti sul mondo del lavoro.
Diminuisce il burnout, l’assenteismo,
e aumenta il benessere.
Il secondo è che praticare gentilezza
migliora la vita di tutti.
Vi faccio un piccolo esempio
di come l’abbiamo applicato in un’azienda
dove lavoro.
C’è un gruppo di colleghi,
un team casuale che condivide
solo la sede di riferimento,
che si ritrova in orario di lavoro
o fuori, e progetta delle idee,
delle attività che siano
di beneficio a tutti.
Ecco, a dicembre hanno inventato
il calendario della gentilezza 2022.
Per ogni mese dell’anno
c’è il suggerimento
di un’azione gentile da compiere.
Ad esempio, lascia un caffè sospeso
per chi verrà dopo di te alla macchinetta.
Oppure lascia un messaggio positivo
sulla scrivania di un collega.
Il terzo beneficio è che fare complimenti
ci rende molto più felici che riceverli
perché ci focalizza sugli altri.
E di questo trae beneficio non solo
il diretto interessato, ma anche qualcuno
di completamente nuovo.
Perché se io faccio una gentilezza ad A
sarà naturalmente più portato a farla
a B, e B a C e così via.
E questo genera una vera cultura della
generosità e della gentilezza
all’interno di un’organizzazione.
Lo scorso anno l’associazione Cor et Amor
mi ha nominata la prima imprenditrice
della gentilezza in Italia. Wow.
Mi sono chiesta perché e credo sia dovuta
al mio stile di leadership gentile.
Certo, ho una naturale tendenza
a sorridere, ma io ho ricevuto
un grandissimo esempio nella mia famiglia.
E tanti altri esempi
Nelle aziende dove ho avuto
la fortuna di lavorare.
Ho vissuto direttamente sulla mia pelle
degli esempi di leadership gentile
e mi è venuto naturale praticarli.
La cosa più incredibile è che negli anni
si sono costruiti dei rapporti di stima
e di amicizia molto forti, sì,
ma insieme noi abbiamo anche fatto
dei numeri straordinari.
Perché la gentilezza nell’azienda
aumenta anche la produttività,
porta anche dei risultati
economici migliori.
Quindi se non è per vero, credo,
per un sano afflato
verso un comportamento gentile,
fatelo per i numeri.
Lo diceva già Esopo nell’antica Grecia:
nessun atto di gentilezza,
per piccolo che sia
è mai sprecato.
Vi dicevo, sono stata nominata la prima
imprenditrice della gentilezza
in quanto donna.
E Guido Stratta, direttore del personale
di tutto il gruppo Enel,
il primo imprenditore.
Ma c’è differenza tra imprenditrice
gentile e imprenditore gentile?
Gli esseri umani sono composti
da 23 coppie di cromosomi.
Gli uomini e le donne si differenziano
unicamente per la 23ª coppia.
Gli uomini sono XY,
le donne sono XX,
e per il resto sono identici.
Si tratta di caratteristiche maschili
e caratteristiche femminili
che abbiamo tutti.
Qui gli studi ci dicono che al carattere
maschile vengono associati dei valori
quali la competizione, la capacità di
essere solo in vetta, consapevoli
che il leader è spesso solo.
Una forza di volontà molto forte, molto
intensa per raggiungere un obiettivo.
È un leader orientato al risultato.
Mentre le caratteristiche femminili
sono associate a dei valori quali:
maggiore sensibilità , un’intelligenza,
intelligenza emotiva più sviluppata,
intuito, empatia e la necessità di
rendersi utili è uno stile di leadership
orientata alla relazione.
Ma si tratta di caratteri maschili
e caratteri femminili, non di genere.
Se dico:
Gentil sesso.
[GENTIL SESSO DONNA]
Voi a chi lo associate?
Alle donne.
E sesso debole?
[SESSO DEBOLE DONNA]
Ve lo ricordate il sillogismo?
Se A è uguale a B, e B è uguale a C,
allora A è uguale a C?
Tiriamolo un po’.
Gentil sesso.
Sesso debole.
Gentile debole, gentile debole.
No.
No, la gentilezza è una forza. È una forza
assertiva che non ha bisogno di violenza
e di aggressività per far valere
le proprie ragioni.
È la capacità di riconoscere
i propri errori e di imparare da essi.
E quindi, come dice un refrain oggi molto
in voga, praticate gentilezza a casaccio
e atti di bellezza privi di senso.
Praticate gentilezza a casaccio
Ma per tornare al carattere,
alle caratteristiche.
Gentildonna, gentil sesso, sì:
la gentilezza è femminile.
Nel 1992 Roberto Vecchioni
cantava Voglio una donna.
Voglio una donna con la gonna,
prendila te quella con il cervello,
quella che fa carriera,
quella col pisello che non c’è mai la sera
E negli anni 90 il modello di
leadership era un modello maschile,
per cui anche le rare donne ai vertici
dell’organizzazione venivano additate
come quelle che portano i pantaloni per
essere un po’ meno prosaici di Vecchioni.
Quasi trent’anni dopo Silvia Zanella
nel libro “Il futuro del lavoro è femmina”
ci dice che nel mondo del lavoro
sono sempre meno richieste
le caratteristiche maschili
e sempre di più quelle femminili.
Ma ricordatevi i cromosomi.
Si tratta di esseri umani,
non di uomini e donne.
Noi dobbiamo allenare sempre di più
Empatia.
Cura, attenzione, entusiasmo, gentilezza.
La gentilezza è sinonimo
di prenderci cura. Cura di noi stessi,
cura dell’ambiente, cura dei luoghi
dove lavoriamo e della comunità
dove noi viviamo.
Tutte le mattine ognuno di voi è davanti
a uno specchio per truccarvi, per radervi,
per lavarvi i denti o semplicemente
per augurarvi buona giornata.
Ecco ogni mattina fate questo esercizio.
Sollevate contemporaneamente gli
angoli della bocca e sorridete.
[SORRIDETE]
(Applausi)
Grazie.